Cameraman: Alright, Michael.
You’ve got 60 seconds.
Michael: I’ll speak really fast and we’ll
get it all in…
Neither the media delegate counters nor the
candidate delegate counters are going to wait
between June 7 and July 18 to see how many
delegates show up at the convention and support
different candidates.
We will know after the June 7 final primaries
whether or not Donald Trump has won in primaries
or caucuses 1237 votes or if he’s visibly
short of that number.
Trump has suggested that this is some kind
of arbitrary number—actually, it’s a majority.
If Trump does not get to 1237—if he’s
visibly short of it—I think that the convention
will move to other candidates, and I think
by far the likeliest nominee in that situation
is Ted Cruz.
What is John Kasich’s strategy to get nominated
at Cleveland in his home state of Ohio?
I think the one problem with Kasich’s apparent
strategy is that always it relies on, as one
essential step, the other guy messing up.
You can’t always rely on that happening.